In this problem, a given soil sample has
been contaminated by an oil spill. The
tuine present in the oil is biodegrading
according to the first order kinetics at
a constant rate of 0.15% per day. If the
initial tuine concentration in the soil
is 22 mg per kilogram, by how much will
the touine concentration be decreased by
in milligs per kilogram after 2 years?
So the first words here to take note of
in this problem are first order and we
need to recognize that this is a decay
problem. Searching decay in the
reference manual will lead us to a list
of equations in chapter 5. This will
lead us to a first order decay equation
which we can fill in every term for
except for the one we are searching for.
So first order decay is going to be
given as CT equals CO E raised to the
minus K * T. CT is going to be our final
concentration which we don't have yet.
CO is going to be our initial
concentration which we can see is given
as 22
mg per kilogram. K is our decay rate
which is going to be equal to 0.15%
per day.
And note that this is going to be
expressed as a decimal. So 0.0015
over days. And then finally t is our
time component which we can see is going
to be 2 years.
Note that since K is in days, we were
going to need to convert years to days
here as well. When in doubt, remember to
follow your units.
So, this equation is quick to set up and
quick to solve. Let's plug in our known
and solve for our unknown.
CT=
mg per kilogram
time E raised to the minus
0. 015
over day
time
day. And our units will cancel and leave
us with a final concentration of 7.35
mg per kilogram. Finally, although we
have an answer and one that's even
listed here, this is not going to be the
one we want to pick. The problem is
asking us by how much will the towing
concentration be decreased by after 2
years. We are looking for the amount the
concentration decreased by between time
0 and time t. That decrease is going to
be equal to the initial concentration
subtracted by the concentration at time
t. So this will be 22 mg per kilogram
minus 7.35
mg per kilogram or 14.65
mg per kg which is not our second answer
but rather our third. So in summary I
think this is a rather easy problem. If
you can recognize that this is a decay
problem and you know where to find the
equation in the manual, you should be
able to solve this problem pretty
quickly. And that's it.